Okay, answer number one, it's not, this is a trick question. It's actually
not a trick question. Multiple app servers means multiple caches, and so we
have to keep them in sync. Yes, that is one source of problems
we are going to face. You know, we have multiple app servers, let's
draw a picture, and we've got our database. And say both of these
guys have their little caches here, you know, let's say both of these
caches are, are, both of these caches are one, they've got their stuff.
Let's say, a database, you know, a POST comes in here that, the results
in a database write, which results in a, in a refreshing of
the cache. Now we got one up server with an up-to-date cache and
another up server with an out-of-date cache. And so if the read
comes in to here We're going to get stale cache. And that's no good.
So we gotta figure figure out a way of keeping these caches
in sync. Each app server may have to hit the database to update
its cache. You know, this is a problem. Let's say the situation
is neither, both of these caches are cold, they're empty. And two read
requests come in, or many read requests come in. This is similar
to the cache stampede problem, where Each of these app servers is
going to want to update its cache which means it's going to have to
hit the database. So that's problematic as well. Now of course we can
alleviate, you know, some of these problems by updating the cache on
writes, but we'd still have to find a way of, you know,
keeping these guys in sync with one another which is a little
tedious. And the final answer we'll
be caching data redundantly. I'm not accepting
that one in this quiz as a bad thing because very often
you do cache data redundantly. That's kind of what a cache is. Right?
You're storing data redundantly and, and I'm actually torn and, and whether
this should be considered a down time or a plus side or kind
of neutral. But, for our purposes, we want to focus on, on these
problems, which is keeping these caches in sync and limiting the number of
database requests we do. Now, the solution we're going to approach here is
going to change this architecture a little
bit. Instead of each app server having
its own cache, we're going to move caching into its
own process. And so now, both these app servers will
use a shared cache. And so, this cache actually behaves
very similar to the database except the queries are much
simpler. They're just key value pairs, and it's probably only
in memory, and there's technology designed. Specifically to solve this
problem. Which is to be fast and used as a
cache. Which is different from a database which is designed
to you know run complex queries on huge
amounts of data. This piece of technology is called
memchached. And we're going to be spending basically the
rest of this lecture learning how to use memchached.